Let's now consider static power, which is what
prevents us from lowering the voltage too much.
Our transistors are really like electronic faucets. Water
comes here, and if the valve is open,
water will flow out. If the valve is closed, no water. But in a transistor it's
like this valve is controlled by water pressure
from another faucet. So if the power supply
voltage is dropped, there is less pressure when the
faucet is closed and as a result, because there is
water pressure here and the valve is not closed
very well. There will be some leakage of water, because
the faucet is not totally closed. So, one component
of static power is this leakage. So the problem is
that, as we lower the voltage, this leakage goes
up. So we reduce dynamic power by lowering the voltage.
But that increases the static power. If we
have already lowered this voltage by a lot, then
the pressure on this valve here is relatively wimpy
already. If we still lower the voltage further, what's
going to happen is we're going to get a much
larger stream of leakage here. So if we draw
the voltage on the horizontal axis and the power
on the vertical axis, what we get is when
the voltage is very high our dynamic power
is also very high, but it drops quickly as
we lower the voltage. So this is our
dynamic power. However, our leakage power is very low
when the voltage is high. And it grows
up very, very quickly because of the increase in
leakage as the voltage is dropped. So our total
power does something like this. There is a voltage
at which the overall power is lowest. If you
increase the voltage further, you're spending too much dynamic power,
so the overall power goes up and you're not
reducing the static power by much anymore. Whereas, if you
go much further down from this voltage, then the
static power becomes very large. And you are no longer
reducing the dynamic power to compensate enough for it.
So this is why modern processors cannot just arbitrarily lower
the voltage to decrease the dynamic power. And also
why they are starting to have problems with static
power because we have already lowered voltage to the
point where the static power becomes an issue. Also
note that the leakage through the transistor like this
is not the only source of leakage that results
in static power consumption. Because the transistors are very
small they're acting as faucets who's valves are now
leaky too simply. Some water is coming through
here. Some of the water that is building up
the pressure is also leaking out and so on.
So there are multiple other sources for why the
static power exists. But to understand the relationship
between static and dynamic power, it's efficient to understand
that, for example, for voltage, dynamic power and static
power are trying to pull the voltage in opposite
direction, and the optimum is somewhere in between.